* Hupen *
An der Zürcher Bahnhofstrasse.
Von aussen nicht erkennbar,
öffnet nach Ladenschluss
das Restaurant von Sami Khouri.
Ich möchte, dass die Leute aus
dem Alltag ausbrechen können und ...
Ich möchte ihnen
etwas crazy-mässiges bieten,
damit sie hierherkommen
und eintauchen können und sagen:
"Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass es in Zürich so etwas gibt."
Ich weiss gar nicht,
wo ich das jemals gesehen habe.
Vielleicht in einem Traum oder so.
Seine Gastro-Projekte
sind verblüffend.
Was ihn vom Rest abhebe,
seien bessere Ideen.
* Chillige Dance-Musik *
Hallo.
Zwei Wochen vorher:
Khouri und sein Team bauen
in diesem leeren Spielwarengeschäft
ein komplettes Restaurant auf,
als Zwischennutzung,
für sechs Wochen.
Wir machen Wäschen,
kalte Küche und warme Küche.
Seit zehn Jahren kreiert er temporäre
Lokale in ungewöhnlichen Räumen:
in Kellern, einer ehemaligen Bank,
einem leeren Kino.
Er soll einfach Samt
vor die Tür hängen.
Man nennt ihn
den Underground-Gastronomen,
seine Lokale Pop-up-Restaurants.
Beides mag er nicht.
Wir sind bereit.
Ich will gewiss nicht
Gastronom sein. Das ist sicher.
Ich würde gerne etwas bauen ...
Wenn mich jemand fragt,
nahm ich mir immer vor, zu sagen:
"Ich bin Schrotthändler."
Warum? Gehört dieser Schrott dir?
Ja, weil ...
Weil, äh ... Das ist einfach Zeug,
das wir kaufen und wieder verkaufen,
Dinge, die Emotionen auslösen.
Dadurch sind wir immer
mit Menschen in Kontakt.
Wir müssen etwas abholen
oder etwas zurückbringen.
Jemand darf hier gratis essen,
weil er mir etwas gab.
Dadurch ist immer etwas los.
Er ist ein Mischler und Macher.
Khouri war 20 und Kameraassistent,
als er anfing,
nebenbei mit gebrauchten Gegenständen
und Chromstahlteilen zu handeln.
... einen Ring um die Küche
installieren.
In seiner Lagerhalle
begann er für seine Freunde -
meist aus der alternativen Szene -
zu kochen.
So entstand die Idee,
in Kellern halb illegale,
temporäre Lokale aufzubauen.
Vielen Dank, ciao.
Bald erhielt er Aufträge von Firmen,
Galerien und Privatpersonen
aus der ganzen Schweiz.
Sein Team ist bis heute dasselbe
geblieben: Freunde und Kollegen.
Das ist ihm wichtig und freut ihn.
Der enge Kern
sind seine Freundin Karenin Gomes,
sein Jugendfreund Joel Heufemann und
Khouris ältere Schwester Dina Bamert.
Insgesamt hat der junge Unternehmer
28 befreundete Angestellte.
Ein grosser Ansporn ist sicher auch,
dass es Geld produziert,
ich damit die Leute bezahlen
und die Leute weiterhin um mich
haben kann, die ich gerne sehe.
Es sind eigentlich
alles meine Freunde.
Ich bin der Motor, der ...
Es ist schon eine eigene Welt,
die wir hier für kurze Zeit haben.
Ich meine ... Wir installieren hier
eine kleine Bar,
eine Bar,
an der sich die Leute bücken
und ihr euch nicht mehr
strecken müsst, eine Mini-Bar.
Diese kleine Welt
soll hier hinten sein.
Man muss beim Trinken
etwas in die Hocke gehen.
Wenn die Show beginnt ...
Die Show beginnt im Lift dort.
Die Eröffnung
des temporären Restaurants.
Wie immer sind Khouris Lokale
aufwendig dekoriert.
Zum Fünfgangmenü
gibt es ausgefallene Shows.
Einlass gibt es für die,
die seine Handynummer besitzen
und per SMS reserviert haben.
Was Khouri macht,
wird zum Stadtgespräch.
Wir treffen ihn im multikulturellen
Langstrassenquartier,
bei seiner Imbissbude
Palestine Grill.
Das war
sein erstes offizielles Restaurant.
Einmal Friedensplatte.
Das hat sich zufälligerweise
durch einen Gastronomen ergeben.
Er sagte:
"Komm, wir machen etwas zusammen!"
Ich meinte:
"Hm, ich weiss nicht, zusammen ..."
"Ich bin nicht so ..." Hallo.
"Ich bin nicht so der Zusammen-Typ,
aber gib mir doch mal deinen Kiosk!"
Er fragte: "Welchen Kiosk?"
Ich sagte: "Der an der Langstrasse."
"Ach, der Grill?
Ja, den kannst du haben."
Ich sagte aus Spass zu ihm:
"Ich eröffne einen Grill
mit palästinensischem Essen etc."
Ich hatte keinen Plan.
Ich redete einfach so daher.
Ich hatte das auch nicht vor.
Ich hatte kein Konzept.
Die Rezepte sind von seiner Mutter.
Sami Khouri
ist in der Schweiz geboren,
seine Eltern sind aus Palästina
und Jordanien eingewandert.
Palestine Grill - steckt da
auch etwas Politisches dahinter?
Nein.
Ich habe zu dieser ganzen Sache zwar
eine ganz klare politische Meinung,
aber als ich den Grill eröffnete,
dachte ich,
dass ich
nicht der 500'000. sein muss,
der seine Meinung
zu diesem Konflikt äussert.
Ich überlegte mir irgendwann,
auch wenn es nicht von Anfang an
ein richtig klares Konzept gab ...
Bei uns gibt es ja z.B. Falafel.
Die Falafel
haben eigentlich beide erfunden.
Israelis, Juden oder Syrer -
alle sagen,
sie hätten die Falafel erfunden.
Wir Palästinenser sagen auch,
wir hätten die Falafel erfunden.
Zudem haben wir Sabich.
Er enthält frittierte Auberginen,
ein gekochtes Ei und Amba-Sauce.
Das ist der Take-away-Renner Nr. 1
aus Tel Aviv.
Das essen Juden in Tel Aviv.
Etwas arabischen Salat.
Das ist Gurkensalat.
All das vereine ich
auf einer Friedensplatte.
Wir schliessen Frieden beim Essen.
Das war eigentlich die Idee.
Wie ist es
als Palästinenser in der Schweiz?
Eigentlich kein Problem.
Ich bin ja auch Schweizer.
Wenn die Schweizer
Fussball-Nationalmannschaft spielt,
bin ich stolz.
Ich bin ein Vollblut-Schweizer.
Ich bin einfach auch noch
Palästinenser und Jordanier.
Und ich ...
Als Palästinenser
in der Schweiz zu leben,
ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Es ist super hier
und es gibt viele Araber.
Wenn man einen Araber trifft
und sagt: "Ich bin Palästinenser",
ist das auch okay.
Sie fühlen sich uns
oft verpflichtet,
weil uns ihre Staatspräsidenten
nicht helfen.
Dann steht man immer gut da.
Wir sind kein verhasstes Volk.
In seinem Leben
ergibt das eine das Nächste.
Budgetpläne sind ihm fremd.
Mit diesem Grill
gründete Sami Khouri
seine Firma Mr. Samigo & Family.
Seine Familie ist ihm wichtig.
Khouri auf dem Weg zu seinen Eltern.
Hier in Zürich
ist der 30-Jährige aufgewachsen.
Familie ist das Wichtigste.
Sie ist ein Halt und man weiss,
dass jemand in guten und
schlechten Zeiten für einen da ist.
(Mutter) Hallo.
- Schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Hallo.
- Hallo. - Geht es dir gut?
Ja.
- Dina, dein Bruder ist da.
(Mutter) Sag Hallo!
Hallo.
Nimmst du auch einen Schluck?
- (Dina) Ja.
Was gibt es heute zu essen?
- Arabische Küche.
Die Eltern sind in den 70er-Jahren
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Sein Vater
arbeitete als Physiotherapeut,
seine Mutter ist seit 23 Jahren
Kinderhort-Leiterin.
Verliert GC, oder wie?
Von klein auf war Sami Khouri
immer für eine Überraschung gut.
Als er ein Kind war, merkten wir,
dass er ganz anders ist
als andere Jungen.
Er hatte einfach mehr Temperament
und wollte
immer neue Ideen umsetzen.
Manchmal
war es für uns nicht leicht,
weil wir immer
"Halt" und "Stopp" rufen mussten.
Die Schule interessierte ihn weniger.
Er machte viel Blödsinn
und musste die Schule wechseln.
Richtig schwierig
wurde es für die Familie,
als er im achten Schuljahr
als "unschulbar" von der Schule flog.
Was geschah denn?
Ja, es war schon blöd. Es hiess ja
nicht von einem Tag auf den anderen:
"Du brauchst
nie mehr zur Schule zu kommen."
Ich tat ja nichts extrem Schlimmes.
Es war nicht so ...
Es war eigentlich ganz gut.
Es klingt blöd, aber für mich
war es super, dass ich gehen konnte.
Ich wollte dort ja auch nicht sein.
Ich lernte neue Leute kennen und ...
Und ...
Man fühlte sich
ja auch ein bisschen cool,
wenn man rausgeschmissen wurde.
Das war ja auch ein Aspekt.
Ja, plötzlich
und einfach unerwartet ...
Nein, nicht unerwartet, aber
für uns Eltern war es nicht leicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
Es gab viele Elterngespräche
mit der Lehrerin.
Er hatte von Anfang an
eine gute Lehrerin.
Ich werde sie nie vergessen.
Sie merkte,
dass er einen so starken Willen hat,
dass wir uns keine Sorgen
über seine Zukunft machen
und an ihn glauben müssen.
So, Amigo, das Essen ist bereit.
Und so war es dann auch.
Auch ohne Schulabschluss fand er
eine Lehrstelle als Siebdrucker.
Als müsste er es allen beweisen,
legte er so richtig los.
Seine Familie arbeitete von Anfang an
bei seinen Projekten mit.
Und dass die ganze Familie
zusammenarbeitet ... - Genau.
Das ist oftmals schön, ab und
zu natürlich auch etwas schwierig,
aber letztlich
finde ich es sehr gut.
Natürlich
ist nicht immer alles einfach,
aber unter Geschwistern
und in der Familie
kann man Probleme
anders ausdiskutieren
als mit Angestellten, zu denen
man keinen so starken Bezug hat.
(Alle) Guten Appetit.
Seine Familie ist sein Team
und sein Team seine Familie.
Im Büro der Firma Samigo & Family:
In diesem kleinen Raum
werden die grossen Ideen geboren.
Wer kauft noch Getränke?
- Weisst du, wofür sie sind?
Ja, aber wir bestellten
auch fürs Personal.
Wir telefonierten am Vormittag kurz
wegen des Militärzelts.
Seit zwei Monaten arbeiten sie
am grössten Projekt des Jahres:
einem Boxkampf-Event.
Guten Morgen, hier ist nochmals
Khouri wegen des Militärfahrzeugs.
Ich wollte nur kurz bestätigen,
dass wir das Auto
am Donnerstag um 11 Uhr abholen.
Khouri lässt nicht gerne
den Chef raushängen.
Alle wissen, was zu tun ist.
Auf seine Freundin Karenin Gomes
kann er sich verlassen,
sie hält die Stellung,
wenn er unterwegs ist.
Wir sind jetzt
seit zwei Jahren zusammen.
Und das ist ...
Ähm, es ist ...
... nicht nur Liebe,
sondern auch Freundschaft.
Wir können uns alles sagen.
Wir sind auch Freunde.
Es ist ...
Es basiert auf der Realität.
Wir arbeiten ja auch zusammen.
Sie ist ja
jeden Tag mit mir zusammen.
Der Boxkampf-Event findet in
einer grossen Halle in Zürich statt.
* Zischen *
* Knall *
Er hat ein grosses Netzwerk: von der
alternativen Szene bis zur Prominenz.
Er gilt als freundlicher Kerl,
den alle mögen.
Rapper Stress probt seinen Auftritt.
V.a. am Anfang,
wenn die Sirene heult,
könnten wir zwei, drei Schüsse
abfeuern.
(Mann) Das könnten wir tun.
- Ja.
Nein, ich glaube,
da muss schon was kommen.
Ja, sonst ist es nur ...
- Wir haben die Bewilligung.
Ja, okay.
- Gleich zwei Schüsse auf einmal.
(Frau) So?
- Nein. Hol den Vorspeisenteller!
Jedes neue Projekt soll das vorherige
übertreffen. Das ist seine Devise.
Und: Sein Team
muss dahinterstehen können.
Alle arbeiten mit Leib und Seele.
76,3.
(Karenin) Sie sind fertig
und liegen ausgedruckt bei uns.
(Über Funk) Super,
dann benötigt Mano morgen Couverts,
seinen Stock und seinen Zettel.
Vor sieben Jahren veranstaltete er
den ersten Boxkampf-Anlass
für 200 Freunde in einem Keller.
Du warst schon mal bei uns, was?
- Vor drei Jahren.
Heute ist es
ein Grossanlass für 1'200 Gäste.
Insgesamt
sind 300 Mitarbeiter im Einsatz.
(Mann) Hier auch noch Lachs, bitte.
25 davon sind Köche.
Trotz dieser kommerziellen Grösse
ist es Khouri wichtig,
seinen Werten treu
und unabhängig zu bleiben.
Ist sonst noch was?
- Wegen diesem Lied ...
Wieso arbeitest du so gerne für Sami?
Wir sind in erster Linie Freunde.
Es arbeitet sich einfach besser
mit Leuten, die man auch privat mag.
Wir sind Samigo & Family,
wir machen das,
weil wir Freude daran haben
und nicht wegen des Geldes oder so.
Wir zeigen gerne spektakuläre Dinge,
die nicht so üblich sind.
Darum macht es auch Spass.
Wichtig ist Folgendes:
Für die Gäste sind wir
alle gemeinsam verantwortlich.
Wir haben alles gemeinsam aufgebaut.
Wir sind ein Team, eine Familie.
Das versuchen wir so durchzuziehen.
(Sami) Jetzt Gas geben!
Alle müssen Gas geben!
In welchem Stadium
ist Samis Stresspegel,
wenn du ihn dir so anschaust?
Ich glaube,
jetzt ist er langsam auf Level 10.
Denn das sind die letzten 2 Std.,
bevor die Leute reinkommen,
und es muss noch geputzt
und kontrolliert werden,
das Personal kommt,
wir müssen alle briefen etc.
(Mann, über Lautsprecher) Tisch 2.
(Mann) Gruppe 2.
Alle, die einen Tisch haben,
stellen sich dorthin!
Wir sind total spät dran,
aber es wird gut.
Auch die Eltern halfen mit,
aber am Abend sind sie Gäste.
(Mann) Hier.
- (Mann) Tipptopp, danke.
In einer Viertelstunde ist Einlass.
Ich bin total nervös,
aber es wird alles gut.
Ich vertraue meinen Leuten.
Jetzt habe ich
gerade ein bisschen ...
Es ist schon ein wenig ...
Es ist nicht alltäglich.
Alles auf Vordermann bringen!
Weg mit der Kiste hier, hey!
Aufräumen, hey! Wer arbeitet?
(Sami) Jetzt wird die Tür geöffnet.
Okay, die Türen sind offen. Alle
reinlassen! Ihr müsst bereit sein.
Die Gäste wissen nicht,
was auf sie zukommt.
Sie erhielten nur eine SMS
mit einer Zeit- und Ortsangabe.
(Mann über Lautsprecher)
Das ist ein Befehl.
Bitte befolgen Sie
alle Anweisungen des Personals!
Ihre Smartphones
werden Ihnen jetzt abgenommen.
Bitte geben Sie
Ihre Smartphones ohne Diskussion ab!
Das Thema: eine autonome Welt,
in der Gangs das Sagen haben.
(Mann) Ladies and gentlemen ...
* Jubel, Pfiffe *
* Muntere mexikanische Musik *
Die einzelnen Boxer ziehen in
Begleitung von autonomen Gruppen ein:
Mitglieder eines
mexikanischen Drogenkartells z.B. ...
(Sami) Winkler, dunkler machen.
Ganz leicht dunkler machen!
... oder Fussball-Fans.
* Unverständliche Fan-Parolen *
Holen, bringen
und wieder zurückkommen.
Aber ist das immer noch ein Problem?
* Jubel, Applaus *
Die extravaganten Showeinlagen
und das Gourmetessen
begeistern die Gäste.
Ein wenig Freude darüber
sieht man Khouri und seinem Team an -
auch wenn sie
nonstop am Rotieren sind.
Ich bin am Funk und dann heisst es:
"Ein Tisch ist runtergefallen,
dies und jenes ist kaputt,
jemand ist Vegetarier
und braucht etwas."
Ohne ihn bin ich tot.
- Jetzt bin ich hier ...
Ich bin wirklich ziemlich fertig.
Ich weiss nicht wie lange ...
Aber es geht noch. Wir trinken
Wasser und ziehen es durch.
* Dynamische Hip-Hop-Musik *
Der Event
ist eine Art Visitenkarte der Firma.
Egal wie hoch die Kosten sind -
Hauptsache,
er wird in aller Munde sein.
Setzt euch alle an eure Plätze!
Der Höhepunkt sind die Boxkämpfe.
* Pfiffe *
Es gibt fünf Kämpfe.
Professionell durchgezogen.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
* Gong *
* Jubel, Applaus *
Es gab schon einen kurzen Moment,
an dem ich merkte,
dass ich am Ende meiner Kräfte bin.
Aber das ist ein gutes Zeichen,
weil ich alles gegeben habe.
Khouri geht an seine Grenzen -
mit allem.
Was er macht und wie er es macht.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Der Boxkampf-Anlass
war ein voller Erfolg.
Finanziell aber nicht.
Die Kosten wurden nicht gedeckt.
Aber das ist in Ordnung für Khouri.
Der gute Ruf zählt mehr.
Ich war so lange nur im Untergrund,
dass ich mich manchmal freue,
wenn jemand eine Rechnung bezahlt.
Dann denke ich:
"Wow, die haben schon bezahlt!"
Ich möchte natürlich
auch Geld verdienen
und die Löhne der Mitarbeiter
bezahlen.
Das ist eine Herausforderung.
Meine Herausforderung ist,
dass alle um mich herum
auch reich werden,
wenn ich irgendwann mal reich bin.
Mir allein bringt es nichts.
Dann sitzen wir alle so da
und wissen:
Durch Sami und mit Sami
haben wir es geschafft.
Das ist noch nicht erledigt. Darum
kümmere ich mich nächste Woche.
Es ist eine Gratwanderung:
den Cool-Faktor behalten
und Rechnungen bezahlen können,
das Underground-Image
aufrechterhalten
und kommerziell erfolgreich sein.
Khouri ist Unternehmer,
er hat Angestellte und fixe Kosten.
Und am Ende
möchte auch er Geld verdienen.
Er ist an einem entscheidenden Punkt
angelangt: Was kommt als Nächstes?
Es tat mir schon jedes Mal weh,
es immer wieder auf- und abzubauen.
Wir waren zwar sehr gut darin,
aber ich muss schon
etwas Ruhe hineinbringen.
Das Auf- und Abbauen macht auch
finanziell nicht immer Sinn.
Andere bauen einmal etwas
und verkaufen dann
20 Jahre lang dasselbe.
Bei uns dagegen
gibt es immer ein neues Bild,
ein neues Plakat und ein neues Logo.
Das ist schon ein grosser Druck
und nicht immer nötig.
Jetzt bin ich 30 und
nun könnte man vielleicht etwas ...
Nicht unbedingt deswegen,
aber ich dachte mir schon lange,
dass irgendwann Zeit ist,
etwas zu ändern.
Ein paar Monate später
treffen wir ihn wieder.
Er wagt den Sprung ins kalte Wasser:
Er übernimmt fix
ein Restaurant am See.
Sonst aber bleibt alles beim Alten:
Familie und Freunde zuerst,
Unabhängigkeit und
gestalterische Freiheiten garantiert.
Ich hatte schon länger das Gefühl,
dass eine Veränderung nötig ist.
Das Kurzfristige,
das Reisen mit dem Restaurant,
diese Pop-up-Restaurants,
wie sie gewisse auch nennen ...
Ich habe das jetzt 15-mal gemacht,
es war viel und ich wollte
eigentlich immer etwas Neues machen.
Etwas sesshafter zu werden,
wäre etwas Neues.
Unternehmer Khouri
fühlt eine Verantwortung
gegenüber seiner Familie,
seinen Freunden und Angestellten.
Aha!
* Lachen *
Er möchte ihnen ein regelmässiges
Einkommen garantieren können.
Es ist einfach schön, dass ich
morgens alle meine Freunde sehe,
die ich kenne, seit ich 14 bin,
und mit denen mich
lustige Geschichten verbinden.
Wir sind jedoch trotzdem eine Firma
und finanzieren uns selbst.
Ich möchte mit meinen Freunden,
meinem Vater, meiner Mutter und
meiner Schwester zusammenbleiben.
Es gibt natürlich noch ganz viele,
die zu uns passen würden.
Das möchte ich zusammenhalten.
Das ist mein grosses Ziel
und meine tägliche Aufgabe.
* Stimmengewirr *
Mit Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten,
die ihm am Herzen liegen,
unabhängig zu bleiben und
immer einen Schritt voraus zu sein:
Super, traumhaft.
Das macht Sami Khouri
erfolgreich und einzigartig.
Das permanente Restaurant
soll nicht Stillstand bedeuten.
Denn wohl wie immer
wird Sami Khouri eine Idee haben
und das eine
wird das Nächste ergeben.